we're continuing to learn in uh fits and
starts and spurts and bits and pieces I
don't know
um more and more about the
extraordinarily bizarre times at
Mar-A-Lago related to this FBI search
warrant the raid the documents Etc and
the latest from The Washington Post is
that Donald Trump told a worker move
boxes of documents after the government
subpoena was received which is another
indicator if true that Donald Trump knew
exactly what was where and was
specifically involved in trying to hide
documents from authorities key witness
and security camera footage there's
video offer evidence of Trump's actions
after the government subpoena people
familiar say
look at this a trump employee has told
federal agents about moving boxes of
documents at Mar-A-Lago at the specific
direction of the former president
according to people familiar with the
investigation who say the witness
account combined with security camera
footage offers key evidence of Donald
Trump's Behavior as investigators sought
the return of classified material the
witness description and footage
described to The Washington Post offer
the most direct account to date of
Trump's actions and instructions leading
up to the FBI search on August 8th
uh where agents were looking for
evidence of potential crimes the people
familiar with the investigation said
agents said agents have gathered witness
accounts indicating that this is the key
element after Trump advisors received
the subpoena in May for any classified
documents remaining at Mar-A-Lago Trump
told people move boxes to his residence
at the property
that description of events was
corroborated by security camera footage
there is video which showed people
moving the boxes said the people who
spoke on the condition of anonymity to
discuss an ongoing investigation no
comment from the justice department
um no comment from Trump's spokesman
Taylor budowich other than the Biden
Administration has weaponized law
enforcement and fabricated a document
hoax in a desperate attempt to retain
political power
um folks this is more evidence of
obstruction this is Trump trying to hide
his alleged violations of the Espionage
Act this was immediately called fake
news
and then of course it's oh we have the
footage we have the video footage we
have the surveillance footage showing a
staffer moving boxes out of the storage
room and moving them to another location
so there is really one major story here
and many dozens of you every single day
write to me and say David there's sort
of like tons of evidence that this guy
obviously should be indicted we're not
saying imprisoned we're saying evidence
for an indictment and then go through
the process and determine whether there
is guilt the real story here to me
continues to be the doj Department of
Justice FBI law enforcement federal law
enforcement investigating all of this
they have an almost absurd amount of
evidence at this point in time to
justify an indictment
doesn't guarantee a guilty verdict it
doesn't guarantee necessarily even a
guilty plea but if this were anyone
other than a former president there is
such extensive evidence that there would
have been an indictment already why is
there no indictment is Merrick Garland
not actually willing to indict we had
this investigation in New York which we
covered and if you've been watching the
show May ring a bell in which two of the
investigators resigned and of course
when this happened the trumpists all
came out of the woodwork and they had
the same story ready to go and that
story was oh the investigators resigned
because they realized it's a Witch Hunt
and there's no evidence
that was wrong the resignations were
actually quite the opposite the
investigators resigned because despite
all of the evidence they were finding
they believed that there was not
actually a willingness from higher-ups
to indict Trump they felt the
investigators felt as though their work
was completely in vain that they were
doing the work they were finding the
evidence and yet they would bring it
bring it bring it to their bosses
and they sensed a total lack of
willingness from their bosses to
actually go through with an indictment
they said what the hell are we doing
here they're we're working in vain we're
working for nothing and they resigned at
this point in time and we will see as
we're recording Today's Show the January
6 committee uh hearing is uh taking
place scheduled to start momentarily you
will probably know more about it than I
know now by the time today's episode
goes live
the amount of evidence is really piling
up here
are we going to get an indictment and
remember I'm actually for Law and Order
so when I say are we going to get an
indictment I don't go to lock anybody up
I don't go to Railroad anyone with
charges what I go to is there seems to
be enough evidence for an indictment
that's the step I'm talking about the
right on the other hand claims to be for
Law and Order and yet they say lock up
Hillary
lock up Joe Biden lock up Hunter Biden
uh lock up antifa lockup BLM lock up
people who haven't even been charged and
in many cases who aren't even under
investigation that's not Law and Order
Law and Order is look at all this
evidence against Trump it's time to
indict that's where we are when you're
looking for a good documentary to watch
you scroll through Netflix and Hulu for
a while there aren't that many you
realize you've seen the good ones what
if I told you there's a streaming
platform exclusively for documentaries
with the best selection where you won't
run out of top quality documentaries
that is curiosity stream with a massive
catalog of the newest and best
documentaries classic titles from years
ago exclusive content you can't find
anywhere else I just watched Pompeii
disaster Street I visited Pompeii in
Italy before I wish I had seen the
documentary before visiting because it
was made very clear I missed a lot when
I actually went to Pompeii you can watch
curiositystream on all of your devices
they're always adding new titles
politics philosophy True Crime nature
they have everything and my audience
gets curiosity stream for under two
bucks a month when you go to
curiositystream.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman the link is down below